but don't feel bad right the Democrats
do understand a lot of other issues and
they're taking them seriously and
they're winning on them Paul Ryan
doesn't understand that earlier this
week Paul Ryan who is still for some
reason using his at speaker Ryan Twitter
handle even though he's no longer the
Speaker of the House he's no longer a
member of the House of Representatives
but nonetheless Paul Ryan got on Twitter
to praise Donald Trump and praised
Republicans and tell us how stupid
Democrats are here's what Paul Ryan
tweeted he said to be clear GOP wins
elections when they're about ideas not
when their personality contest like dims
and media want we're clearly better off
because of a trio Donald Trump his
record of accomplishment is why he'll
win re-election especially when compared
to Dems leftward lurch leftward lurch
he's talking about Dems I'm assuming he
means the very very crowded field of
2020 Democratic candidates and the new
crop of progressives that was recently
sworn into Congress back in January but
I wonder if that includes the leftward
lurch of the entire country perhaps
former speaker Ryan could answer that
question for us because as we've all
discussed here at progressive media poll
after poll after poll has shown us that
these far left
socialistic ideas actually hugely
popular with all Americans regardless of
political party that's why a majority of
Republicans support Medicare for all as
do super majorities of independents and
Democrats majorities support the $15
minimum wage majority's support
expanding Social Security and Trump on
the other hand and the Republicans just
want to cut it by twenty five billion
dollars with their new budget Americans
want that expanded Americans like the
idea of debt-free college by
overwhelming margins they like the idea
of the planet not burning down because
of climate change
so if Paul Ryan thinks that DIMMs have
made a leftward lurch and it's gonna
cost them the election I might suggest a
Paul Ryan perhaps go look at some polls
maybe maybe get
there and get a feel for the American
public because you've clearly lost touch
with them through your time in office
and hey right now you've got nothing but
time on your hands buddy get out there
and talk to people reconnect with
Americans see what's actually happening
pick up a newspaper for God's sake and
read the latest polls Democrats will
lose in 2020 to Donald Trump if they
don't recognize the leftward lurch as
you so aptly called it but it's not the
leftward lurch of the Democratic
politicians it's the leftward lurch of
the American public because here's what
the public wants right now they want
substantive and transformational change
they do not want the same old same old
they understand that they can't pay
their medical bills and that something
has to be done the private sector isn't
going to do it the private health
insurance companies the private health
care companies Hospital corporations Big
Pharma they have been given every
opportunity to do the right thing lower
their cost and stop working over
American citizens with their bills we
have been talking about this as a
country for over a decade the rising
cost of drugs the rising cost of
hospital care the rising cost of
insurance they knew we were mad about it
members of each of those groups has gone
and had to answer to Congress for why
they're jacking up prices on us for no
reason and none of them stopped doing it
they've had their chance they've had
multiple chances and they failed to do
it and the American public recognizes
that so the only solution at this point
is some kind of Medicare for all program
that essentially is going to eliminate
private health insurance companies who
again raise our prices for no reason
it's going to force drug companies to
lower their prices through Medicare
negotiation which is part of some of the
legislation out there it's desperately
needed it's going to force the hospital
corporations to reduce their prices
it would fix a lot of things and as we
all know has the benefit of also
providing us with an extra two trillion
dollars over the course of about a
decade it saves us money it saves lives
it's the best thing for this country and
yet Paul Ryan the man who was so
terrified about running against Randy
Bryce that he decided to retire doesn't
seem to understand it and warns us that
this leftward lurch is going to be bad
for America even though America really
seems to love this leftward lurch of the
Democrats we're about out of time for
today but don't forget for members we
have the bonus show coming up and I'm
gonna run through what's happened this
week with the democratic party's
nominees got some new folks in the mix
so you don't want to miss my take on
that don't forget you can subscribe to
David Pakman zoo to be a tree on help
support the show become a member and if
you want more from me you can find me on
Twitter at fair and balanced fa rro in
balanced the same for me on Instagram
and on Facebook and every day ring a
fire we offer you brand new videos 7
days a week on our YouTube become a
subscriber youtube.com slash the Ring of
Fire
I want to thank David and his entire
team very much for letting me sit in
today I am fair and cousins in for David
Pakman thank you for watching